Elizabeth Banks legend I tell you is
still to my knowledge the only guess we
know who has invented their own board
game let's make it a tradition we will
play around I give you this is Elizabeth
Banks board game this is before like the
internet happened I mean what do you
mean this before the internet I just
mean it's you know if this was at a time
when I was going a lot of hen parties
out so you call them here right
bachelorette parties and felt like we
needed to actually sort of organize them
around something and this game came out
of that okay we've selected a few
questions from I'm already nervous you
me quiz master you know so this is a
combination there's the you open your
mouth and play this with your friends
out at the bars right one when you're
about don't do the spit swallow question
you did last time what I'm not playing
to do something involving someone else
and sometimes you have to do something
just for yourself and it's sort of like
truth or dare okay what the game is
about so for instance hmm all right
okay yeah yeah hi this is a good in the
freezer because you're loved up right
you're loved up you have a part alright
so the question here this is a say
question which means she has to tell us
what she would say so the question is
I've stopped breathing not by no you
don't have to be in charge
do this yeah yeah wow this is actually a
very nice it's this nice safe boy okay
how do you signal to a partner that you
want to have sex
[Laughter]
signor
[Laughter]
safehouse
that's the good one okay now what we do
what were he and then Ricky Hogan answer
you have great answers for that one by
the way you honk the bell I got it I
thought that was really good okay this
is the name game right what have you
named your private parts Pamela
I'm having the boys
[Applause]
and her sons yes
this isn't this is a really nice one for
you Graham alrighty yes what what songs
always puts you in the mood Oh
s cup seven reache
[Applause]
final one final one okay bottom up um oh
this is perfect for you okay alright are
you ready yeah
it's called sexy singer mmm find an
unattractive male and serenade him
[Laughter]
[Applause]
respective it
quickly the line of a song quick look at
look up look up and then will you play
the role for me
go on in
[Applause]
then come closer
right
[Laughter]
my god it's gonna get a leg on it you
don't remember me but I remember you not
so long ago you broke my heart in two
[Applause]
[Music]
you